I'm still working with these people man
I can't tell you that this is the most
complicated season ever so this is nice
it's really nice to like reflect Tyrion
is a happy black sheep he sort of has
figured out his way of survival it is
true what they say about the northern
girls he's found a comfort zone with the
drink and you know going to the brothels
as opposed to going to the more
political meetings
now the staffs are feasting us at
sundown I've begun the feast a bit early
and this is the first of many courses
but he's not challenging himself I think
he's sort of lost there's sort of no
question that if it wasn't all that war
declared we would win but Tyrion doesn't
want to see his home destroyed innocents
die so he's trying to circumnavigate
that and find a peaceful solution we
turned the Dragons loose tens of
thousands will die in the firestorm it's
called war but she listens to him I am
NOT here to be queen of the ashes and
thus begins this complicated path of
this of that season the army of the dead
is real the White Walkers are real the
knight King is real I've seen them if
they get past the wall and we're
squabbling amongst ourselves we're
finished it's sort of the enemy of my
enemy is my friend at this point because
the real threat is are the White Walkers
and the knight King and they're coming
and they don't discriminate knowing that
they can't win by themselves they need
though the allies of Cersei and her
Lannister army Tyrion hatches a plan
says he thinks the army of the Dead is
nothing but a story made up by witnesses
to frighten children what if we proved
her wrong
and so we bring a white to Dez neck pit
we have something to show you
and we unleash this white onto Cersei as
proof
but I guess that wasn't enough to
convince her the dead will come North
first enjoy dealing with them we will
deal with whatever is left of you it's a
great scene because he realizes he's not
gonna change the relationship especially
in this forum
but he's so tired of the same old same
old
especially in that room that where his
father's sat in judgment of Tyrion so
many times and now that Cersei is
sitting in that same chair hey why don't
you just kill me weren't you just just
enough put your money where the mouth is
because I'm done do it
say the word
she might kill him in that moment as
happy she doesn't and then he realizes
she's pregnant that's the main reason
he's convinced she's going to go through
with this plan and again like the show
always does they pull they even pull the
wool over the character's eyes not just
the viewers but the characters hey
everybody its charlie we got a brand new
Game of Thrones Season eight Tyrion
promo to break down I feel like it'd be
best to do his after doing the Cersei
season a promo because she spent so much
of it talking about Tyrians character
and Tyrion spends most of his talking
about Cersei his family in trying to
avoid killing all them during season
seven and especially during season eight
it'll be really important for what
happens during season eight because it's
the holidays we're doing a new round of
that Song of Ice and Fire book giveaway
all you have to do to enter is be a
subscriber and leave a comment on the
video the fun thing about Peter Dinklage
talking about Tyrion during season one
or preceding the events of season one
when he's at Winterfell they have that
big moment we know in season eight
episode one they're going to be arriving
at Winterfell in the first really big
scene you have to imagine after him
talking about Tyrion during the pilot
episode him coming full circle in season
8 episode 1 also compounded by the fact
that Jaime will be arriving there at
some point during that episode as well
he talks about Tyrion self-medicating
with drink with women not challenging
himself not really doing anything to
participate in the politics of the day
now he said Daenerys is small Council
and probably one of the smartest
strategists that they have on their team
although you know for the season 7
episodes you wouldn't know it based on
the way they wrote it I haven't always
been super happy with the way they've
written Tyrion the last couple of
seasons since they've run out of book
material but you still get that sense
for his character arc like he's slowly
come into his own the same way the Jaime
has slowly found his moral compass so
they have all these innate abilities and
talents at the beginning of the story
that they're not taking advantage of
that by now pretty much everybody all
the main characters even Cersei as cruel
as she seems screwing everyone over have
become fully actualized people when
Peter Dinklage calls this season the
most complicated season I think that
he's saying that for a number of
different reasons if the reason he says
I can't say that man I still work with
these people is probably because the
person on the other side of the camera
just asked him to say something bad
about one of his cast mates because they
really have been
working together for the last 10 years
but Peter Dinklage himself in real life
still does a lot of work at HBO but he
calls Season 8 the most complicated
season for real like three main reasons
because one it is the final season so
they have to find a way to end the
series on a high note that at least you
know I'd say half the fandom is happy
with you're never gonna please everyone
but you don't want to wind up with a
lost situation where most of the fans
are really upset that's also part of the
reason why Dan and Dave admitted to
closing down the series before they
could have like HBO would be happy to
have 10 or 20 seasons of Game of Thrones
they would just keep paying for it no
matter how much it cost every major show
that's gone past ten seasons just cannot
maintain the level that fans come to
expect a bit and you have showrunner
changes which you know whatever you
think of Dan and Dave and their ability
to adapt a Song of Ice and Fire
you have to imagine that new show
runners coming on would make that even
worse so they're just wanting to end
things on a high note before it gets
really bad - from a production
standpoint it's really complicated
because there's so much extra CG
remember when that special effects
supervisor freaked everyone out by
saying that season 8 was gonna take even
longer to finish because of the types of
shots that they were trying to do so
that's all just in service of them
closing it down in the best possible way
but obviously they came out HBO was like
no no no don't worry we're releasing it
during April 3 probably the most
important reason why it's the most
complicated season is because of the
decisions the characters have to make
are the most complicated that they've
made the entire series run a really good
example is Tyrion saying that he loves
his family in spends pretty much all of
season seven trying to find the least
bloody way of taking the iron throat
because he doesn't want to kill his
family and he doesn't want to burn down
what he considers his home Daenerys even
takes him to task for it during the
season she accuses him of being more
loyal to her family because they're
doing so poorly in their fight against
Cersei but even though that's not the
case I feel like that's gonna come back
around in a big way during season eight
because that scene that they have
together after the dragon pit in Tywin's
old office the office of the hand is
probably one of my favorite scenes from
all of season seven just because those
actors are so good and there's so much
pathos between those two characters that
has been building up ever since
Joffrey's death in the trial
Tyrion challenges her to
kill him just to end things between them
just because he's so sick of all the
bullcrap she refuses because she still
cares about him and thinks of him his
family and Tyrion thinks the baby like
we've been talking about the ticking
time bombs at a Circe's baby and what it
might do to her during season eight is
it hearing feels like that baby is his
chance to reason with her like while
she's got that baby she'll think clearly
little did he know that she would use
the baby as justification to screw all
them over but at this point in the story
she's still firing mentally on most of
her cylinders so you have that idea of
Tyrion being loyal to his family not
wanting to kill them think about how
complicated it would be the choice that
Tyrion would have to make if Daenerys
ordered Tyrion to either kill Cersei or
kill a bunch of people to get to Cersei
to things that he's dead set against
doing that would actually probably be
the biggest reason for him to betray
Team Jon and Daenerys asking him to do
something that just goes against his
core operating beliefs I'm not going to
kill my family I refused to so that is
about as complicated as you could get
for Tyrians character but the other
really cool thing that he talks about
during this promo is the season for when
he killed Tywin he talks about his
reasons for doing that I know there's a
long-standing theory that maybe Tyrion
is part Targaryen because some people
believe that he might secretly be the
son of the mad king who took advantage
of Joanna Lannister and that's part of
the reason why Tywin hates him so much
then I just find my father in the Privy
and I put a bowl to him because he still
refuses to
accept me as his son but when you hear
Peter Dinklage talk about Tyrion killing
Tywin simply because he refused to
acknowledge him as his son even when
he's sitting there with a crossbow in
his face threatening to kill him he
still refuses to give him the love that
he's wanted his entire life the reason
why I don't think the Tyrion is secretly
a Targaryen is is because that moment
doesn't work if he's not really Tywin
son it would be really easy for Tywin to
say oh well you're not my son because
you literally not my son it's so much
more meaningful for those characters and
so much more dramatic if he really is
Tywin son in Tywin still refuses to give
him that love it's the exact same kind
of thing the Tywin's done to Cersei her
whole life basically treat her like a
piece of meat just passing her around
using her as a pawn in his game of
Thrones so let me know in the comments
Peter Dinklage teases that season eight
will be the most complicated for the
characters what do you think Tyrians
most complicated decision he'll have to
make is going to be because it's the
holidays I'll try to keep my schedule as
much as possible so they'll be more Game
of Thrones promos coming leave all your
requests in the comments below
congratulations Matthew Cosette you're
the giveaway winner from my last big
video please email me on the about page
of my channel so I can get your details
click here to watch that Game of Thrones
Season eight Cersei promo and click here
for the Arya Stark in the rest of the
season a promos thank you so much for
watching everybody stay awesome and
Happy Holidays
you